ladies and gentlemen the legend hello
Yakov has entered the studio Yakov
Smirnoff is here yo what's going on man
how are you
oh I'm doing fantastic I I just got a
text from our mutual friend Lisa oh yeah
she's my friend Lisa yeah yeah I was the
comedian I worked with I know I know her
yeah but he said your show is amazing so
whoa oh my god it's off to a rocky start
the mic yeah coughs microphone just felt
that doesn't happen at the yakov theater
does it no no no I also toured with dice
for a few years he loves you he talks
about you you think he makes me laugh
more than anyone and I learned English
from him you know yeah all the nursery
rhymes aye aye that's probably a problem
it's probably not a guy to learn English
how did you meet dice I met him at the
Rodney Dangerfield club here in New York
and it was our first gig that we got
actually paid him and I got paid $40
each and I was a little intimidated by
him because he's big guy leather jacket
kind of a stereotypical a hoodlum kinda
yeah yeah not something I am attracted
to but and hidden in the darkness of the
club he was like a yak you and I were
good team you know and I'm like oh boy
this is so I move what are you gonna say
no yeah yeah we are moving to California
I thought that how not gonna see him
ever again
and then he knocks in the door Mitsy
short the owner of the comedy store had
a place where comedians could rent right
and so he was the next batch of
comedians and I was already there and he
knocks on the door and I'm going oh no
yeah yeah I told you were a good team
we're gonna be together and so we were
roommates for three years Wow
you know my critize long before anything
oh yeah
yeah yeah he at that time he was just
doing impressions of John Travolta and
Sylvester Stallone and the Elvis who
used to close his act with Elvis songs
and and and then HBO young comedian
special gave him a chance to be seen by
national audience and took off from
comedy club to Madison Square Garden and
what about Kinnison back in those days I
know he was a did he live there first or
did he live there empty you know he he
never actually lived he would just show
up and crash there after nights of doing
I mean there was a funny house because a
lot of people come there Robin Williams
would come there sand Kennison and they
would they would get together like at
you know one o'clock in the morning and
I was working mid seer hired me as a
carpenter I didn't speak English so I
was like working there as a carpenter
and go to bed early and then I wake up
and they would just go to bed and I go
downstairs and there's a mirror on it on
the table and I couldn't understand why
there was like powder on it and and I
thought they were eating doughnuts right
in the mirror don't eat doughnuts on
that mirror right so I would say I would
wipe it off bring it back and I would
tell him next morning I said what are
you guys doing why can't you use plates
you know you have dishwashers here in in
America and they would laugh and nobody
would tell me what was going on so that
was my introduction to to Hollywood with
them then them leaving Koch members I
love it if you getting past any drug
sniffing dogs they would have smelled it
all over your hands from I think so you
learn English from just being here yeah
yeah I I didn't speak English when I got
here yeah how do you learn English and
then transfer it into humor like how do
you like all of a sudden while you're
already here you learn like okay this is
how you speak and this is where the joke
is well I was comedian I was a comedian
in Russia which was hard for Americans
that those days to imagine even that
there was such thing as a Russian
convenient sounds like Mormon wino right
now
and so death was a curiosity factor
right
away when I when I got here so but I I
was hoping to be able to do comedy but I
didn't know if I can or not so I got a
job well I collected my parents and I
came together no money we're living in
Washington Heights in the tiny apartment
and I I realized that I need to learn
English so I figured where can I learn
and make a living at the same time
decide to become a bartender and I got
it was $200 degree that you can get to
become a mixologist and so I have that
degree 200 bucks and it was on 42nd
Street like on East Side there was a
school of mixology so I would go there
don't speak English I would bring that
clunky big tape recorder from Russia and
I would record every lesson and then I
would slowly translate what they were
talking about Bloody Mary or grasshopper
or you know or dry martini or whatever
and that became my learning tool to
learn the language what's crazy now like
now on the phone you have these like
Translate or google translator you can
hit a button yeah and back then you have
to bring a big shitty recorder and go
over it word by word yeah and look it up
yes hey when you would back then when
you're doing stand-up in Russia like
there's all these like you weren't
allowed to say certain things right you
couldn't criticize the government or you
you couldn't talk about government sex
religion and politics the rest was fine
right what did you stick to fish it was
literally there was a mother-in-law joke
joke something that would not get in
your head place and you would get
approved by the Department of jokes once
a year they would you would submit your
material and they stamp it really yes
every state had Department of jokes and
then it would go to Moscow which was the
big Department of jokes or a Minister of
Culture had literally Department you
were the music dance jokes all of that
and who is there any that were flagged
you could think
like what the [ __ ] is they flag that for
yeah yeah but yeah we had to be careful
to begin with when we were submitting it
but I remember a joke that I submitted
it was about little aunt got married to
female elephant and after their first
wedding night elephant died and the
little ant said only one night I enjoyed
myself and now for the rest of my life I
have to dig this grave pretty funny
funny right yeah but they thought I was
talking about the Communist Party yeah
oh yeah because it was it was they were
so concerned that people will rebel then
I even that kind of subtle you change
the joke to hippopotamus ah well I'll go
back and redo that so was your mind
blown when you come to the States and
you see that there's I mean literally no
restrictions on what anyway she came out
with Dyson Tennyson yeah well even prior
to that I remember being in New York I
lived here for like six months and I
went to play book club and there was a
comedian there and he said that Jimmy
Carter just had a hemorrhoid operation
and he's going to be perfect [ __ ]
again right I literally I was all in the
back of the room I docked I didn't
realize I was like holy that somebody's
gonna shoot this nomination from
somebody so I don't want to be
associated with this when things
wouldn't things hit the fan and so that
was my the conditioning I over the years
you know but I you know I'm not
complaining because it was kind of a
great training for comedy for at that
time the clean comedy was the only
comedy that would get on television so
for me I was already knew how to walk
between the lines you know they're not
cross them and it worked for me how did
you deal with Fame I mean
coming from where you came from and then
coming to the country and learning you
know English through being a bartender
all of a sudden at one point in your
comedy career you just blow up you
becoming this enormous high the Cold War
figure yeah in the 80s you know you know
you got all this money you got all that
you could you freedom to do whatever you
want yeah and you've never had that
before
no no and if that was happening
gradually it feels like it happened
overnight or they didn't really yeah
he took me like six years together in
The Tonight Show for example you know so
I was earning every step of the way I
was earning my keep here and so and then
at some point it was mid 80s when I you
know I got sworn in as the American
citizen here in New York at the Statue
of Liberty and that was a big shift
there too because I was there and
Baryshnikov was supposed to be sworn in
at the same didn't they had this big
event and all the media was there to
cover or talk to Maurice income and
everybody kind of ignored me III would
they didn't see me and and then
perversity goes FBI guys came out and
said he's going to performing later
tonight he's not going to give any
interviews and all of these reporters
from Time magazine Newsweek New York
Times LA time everybody was there they
they were standing waiting for
Baryshnikov and I was like hanging out
waiting for this thing to happen they're
like piranhas turned and went for me and
I'm alone there no PR person nobody and
they're like okay I'm with Time magazine
I never I'm with Newsweek and you get
something yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly so all the sudden I'm like I'm
going who are you with People magazine
could you wait here I'll talk to time
and then I'll talk to Newsweek then I'll
come back to you so all the sudden it
just became like I don't think it will
ever happen it was just happen to be the
build-up of that Amer
konna Statue of Liberty unveiling all of
that was building up to this event and I
just happened to be in the middle of it
and I'm rushing and that was kind of a
track you know Russia was the archenemy
of the u.s. success well how how was it
for business now because they're trying
to they're trying to get ready to back
to being the archenemy of us you perform
for try right I would say it again have
you performed for Trump I I have do you
worry that they'll bring that well
actually I did wasn't planning on
performing for Trump I was invited it
was actually Sakura yeah she was at we
were in Florida we were writing stuff
and and she got an invitation to go to
Mara Lago to do this comedy show a
couple of months before and so I you
know and she said she texts me like
couple of days before then and she goes
you know what I have this gig and I
think Trump is gonna be there and I went
ok and and and when was this huh
when was that was last two weeks ago
that's amazing yeah and so I said well I
I would like to you know jump into
perform just because it's an unusual
spot and sure so so and they said sure
great so I was able to perform and there
I met Trump I worked at Trump Plaza
Hotel for years I never met him there
and I'm I and in Branson he brought in
Miss America pageant know Miss USA
pageant that was here and and and so I
met him there and you know in Branson
I'm a big shot you know we did
billboards and all of that and so he
said well this is your town and I said
well you have yours I got mine so so
that was the only interaction you know
that that we had but it was an
interesting opportunity to perform but
but the what was happening in the 80s
the country was united against Russia
and Gorbachev was kind of making the
bridge but there
was unity here we're not we're not
united so Russian humor doesn't really
he works a little bit but it doesn't
carry me for the two-hour show you know
and so it's an interesting thing I'm
performing at Stockton University this
Friday and at the Performing Arts Center
and then in Chimel the Center here in
New York City at the Pace University so
so I'm doing like an hour and a half
show and my show is focused kind of a
down the memory lane a little bit but my
future what I see I'm just about to
graduate with my doctorate degree from
Pepperdine University in California I
got my master's degree in psychology
from University of Pennsylvania so I'm
kind of became a professor at Missouri
State University teaching course
unhappiness and laughter so I'm kind of
I used to help to end the Cold War in
the war room now I'm trying to end the
Cold War in the bedroom you know and I I
add in so much more job security there
yeah yeah because when the Soviet Union
collapsed
shift for me David Letterman had a
top-10 list of things will now change
and I made number one on the list Yakov
Smirnoff will be out of water
it's bad for business when he was not
good for me at first I thought it was
kind of funny yeah but then six months
later none of my none of my shows that
were I had the contracts Vegas Atlantic
City Reno Tahoe none of them were
renewed so I started looking for a place
where they did not know that the Soviet
Union collaborative and that's how
Branson Missouri ended up in Branson
Missouri I swear to God I didn't want to
go uh-huh but there was no nobody would
hire me honestly ow yeah and I mean just
a total shock to the system because you
were one of the hottest comedians in the
world for Reagan oh and now all of a
sudden it's over yeah it was over in the
in like six months and I'm like I just
said it was years years years bill bill
exactly and now we're done done and and
there was nobody talked to it what am I
gonna say hey put the ball back what am
I gonna you know there's no there's
nothing I could do right yeah so I my
agent calls me and he said I can't get
you a new work but Willie Nelson has
this Farm Aid concert and he would like
you to co-host it's a it's a there's no
money in it but you know if you want to
do it so I said well Ames I though is a
place I always want to and sure I'll go
and I went there and I was like real
nervous I mean 40,000 people the old
farmers and I'm like what do I know
about farming you know and and Willie
Nelson introduced me and this 40,000
people gave me a standing ovation and I
was like holy cow and I said listen I
don't know about farming I went I was on
you know on the farm once and the guy
played practical joke and me he he he
let me milk his bull and I learned
something you milk discernable once you
have a friend for life and and the crowd
went crazy for me and so Willie after
you know the concert I went to his
trailer and he was like between puffs of
smoke and you can't even see him behind
this smoke and I'm and he's like kid you
should go to Branson Missouri they'll
totally get you and I was like what's a
branson missouri you know and then i
checked it out when Willie Nelson tells
you to do yeah then you do it you do it
and when you perform for Reagan how did
that happen like I hear to you on The
Tonight Show it's like oh no no no no no
it was I was playing the small club in
Washington DC
it was called the comedy cafe I know if
it's still there or not and the the guy
who chief editor or Washington Times are
no borscht graph he's passed down now
but he saw me and he was there and he
you know came over and he is like you
know guy I didn't
back to say to me hey you're funny I'm
having President Reagan and Nancy Reagan
at my apartment for dinner would you
like to join us
Ryan Wow man and the only he was with a
very attractive wife and I'm going well
maybe he I don't know who the guy is but
you know okay so I gave my phone number
he calls me next day got tickets for me
too you know and we get I get to
Washington and he meets me at the
airport we're going to his apartment and
I don't know if you guys know when the
there the president shows up there's
like block of the whole neighborhood the
helicopters are on on above the the
buildings it was scary crazy kind of a
you know and so he we pull in fully and
and they they ask for the ID from the
owner of this apartment and he goes I'm
hosting the president they said well we
don't care we need to check your ID and
then they asked him to step out they
searched him I'm going Oh what chance do
I have I just I just got out of Russia
right and and the guy shines a light on
me the FBI guy shines a light on me and
then he goes miller lite commercial
right I go yes he goes go in so so the
president comes in and this is like
unreal this is like totally like in the
movie scene and I'm standing there
there's only 18 people at this apartment
and they're all like Secretary of State
you know big big Secretary of Defense
and it's like and and the president
walks in and they introduce me and they
said this is Yakov Smirnoff he's a
Russian comedian and and the president
immediately says have you heard this
joke and he tells me right away a joke
about the Russian guy who wants to buy a
car and in those days took forever and
to buy a car in the Soviet Union so he
goes to a factory the manager said put
your name on the list come back in 20
years pick up the car the
guy said though I come back in the
morning or an afternoon and the manager
said what's the difference 20 years from
now the guy said the plumber is
scheduled to come back boy I cracked up
and we connected immediately and for the
whole house the whole evening now this
was a this was a pretty interesting
evening because Reagans and helicopters
military helicopters to scare Qadhafi so
for the whole night the West dinner was
going on first of all they had like in
the spare bedroom they had the whole
Hospital set up just in case you know
they they do it in a bedroom huh right
there yeah covered the windows with
plywood so nobody can see in I mean it's
pretty it's pretty big operation when
the president of that and and so and
behind him for the whole evening stands
this marine in a very traditional kind
of a with the football which contains
all the nuclear codes for launching an
attack right there from the dinner table
Wow in football in the football it's
like a briefcase yeah I see and and he
they call it football but he's standing
there holding it and his job is not to
break a smile really for the whole time
and him and he's standing like we're
right behind the president and I'm
looking at him straight on and and I'm
and we're all everybody's cracking up
and he's standing there trying to yeah
can't I can't laugh I can laugh
so there was a pretty interesting night
so the whole night we were just telling
jokes to one that's amazing and I fresh
out he left and I was like going what
just happened yeah yeah did just happen
and then after that couple of months
later I get a phone call from President
Reagan's head speechwriter who is now
congressman in Dana Rohrabacher he's a
congressman in Orange County and and he
says President Reagan this very
confidential but President Reagan's
gonna go to Russia to meet with
Gorbachev for the first
and this is a big deal because he won
nope nope American president have not
been in the Soviet soil in decades so he
wants to do a speech in front of all the
Russian politicians in Kremlin so
President Reagan asked if you were to
write jokes for his speech Wow and I'm
like I'm thinking if this doesn't work I
don't have any country I saw but how do
you say no sure like that so I wrote
jokes and they liked them to put they
put them in the speech and then they
they send me the speech they said would
you mind looking it over the speech if
we're in the right track I go ok mind
the most qualified person punch-up
Reagan speech yeah so they send me the
speech and I didn't like it I mean I
thought you know it was kind of talking
down to the like telling them what they
need to be doing and I'm saying and I
said I don't really think that it's
appropriate to take that tone because to
them you know they're gonna get offended
and that's not I don't think that's what
the president wants to do right and and
they said well then can you rewrite the
speech I'm like oh this is too crazy so
but idea that put some comments in it
and you know and I wrote what I thought
it was just shifting the tone of it and
they liked it and that's how it went so
you come over you literally learn
English and you're doing bartending
classes and then a few years later
you're punching up a speech that
Reagan's for the matrix which have in
Russia mm-hm
unbelievable Russia I have a question
about Branson yeah I've never been to
Branson but I know that you were a king
there for a very long time yes and while
I've never been to Branson we have seen
the commercial for yeah coughs
dinner theater yes multiple times now
here's the question yes you go over all
the highlights of all the great things
that people can enjoy as part of the
night and then the show and the dinner
and the and the magnetic trays and
everything yeah one of the big
highlights is that there are real
linen napkins yeah and that is
highlighted in the commercial why in
Branson do you feel like when we're
advertising our theater real linen
napkins is going to be a selling point
okay yes okay thanks to youtube for
that's behind the scenes what in what
that really was just met with mr.
Branson stays in Branson okay and linen
napkins is one of those things right
nobody ever mentioned that but it was I
was trying to get some advantage over
there's some there's some very
successful venues that serve dinner and
I only did it for like a year after that
I realized that I'm not in the food
business that's not gonna happen but he
was kind of creative because we were
able to feed like 2,000 people in 20
minutes right and it was really the real
good food and everything was so natural
yeah candles - I know I heard about the
candles on the trays as well
I know trying to take some advantage
because we're still seeding on on the
airplane kind of seats show and so it's
not finesse are you thinking that if I
put in the commercial there's real linen
napkins here that people are gonna be
like the classy joint this is the real
deal I'm gonna taste my water then yes
exactly
nice what I was hoping for you didn't
work it didn't work long-term it did not
work I'll tell you if I take my wife out
to a place your linen napkins I do and
they give me paper net and embarrass
totally linen napkins says class enjoy
the show
enjoy the food oh you got a little
something on your hands and Kim there's
a linen napkin and a nice candle a
candle yes
hey were you married when you came to
the States no no no no I probably had a
good run with women then when I did and
got married to an American not real
American she's from Oregon - two
children Oh Natasha and Alexander took
us a while to figure out their names
because when our daughter was born my
wife wanted the real America
named for her brandy and I said brandy
Smirnoff why don't we just had their xxx
half day care center so she can play
with Jim Beam and Johnny Walker and so
what was the interesting about that
relationship and that's why I'm on my
I'm on second marriage now because the
laughter that was an interesting core as
a comedian I know there's something that
there was so much laughter in the
beginning of the relationship and then
slowly kind of went away right I didn't
notice it now with my audience if it
happened I would have no this sure first
joke right second joke for sure but I
didn't and over the years and then we
eventually broke up and I started
learning about this correlation between
happiness and laughter and I realized
that laughter is the first thing that
people rely ask for over four and a half
million people in my theater how many of
you would go on the second date if he
didn't have laughter in the first date
applaud no one four and a half million
people we're using laughter as a gauge
whether we're connecting with that
person or not whether that person has
ability to meet our needs or not is
their sense of humor matches our sense
of humor it's like catching the release
program right right literally I mean and
then you finally hook somebody with the
same sense of humor and that's a great
catch and you stuff them and you put
them on the wall did you that did you
have the opportunity to pick up tail
while you were in Branson because you
were the king there or were you married
or both and I I actually I'm very I was
married when we got there then I got
divorced I I musta been awhile time the
eve or I'm not complaining but I but
catching the release I mean I went
through a lot of catching and a lot of
lease it for you
quickly and then release it release your
date but I I'm married to a very
beautiful Ukrainian lady this is
something that I decided that I'm going
to go back to my oh wow roots yeah she
engine yes oh my god and so fantastic
yeah and does she laugh at your jokes
yes and we're good yes beautiful woman
who laughs at your jokes yes man and the
point is she makes me laugh too so it's
like really amazing and and so now I'm
paying attention to this because
laughter is the first thing we
experience when we meet right right
second thing is later it's like intimacy
third thing you live together and get
married when things don't go well
laughter is the first thing to go
second thing is intimacy third is your
house I know not to do it again that's
when you're sleeping in your dinner
theater yeah I'm not leaving napkins to
the right exactly
one more gemandsam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app